Künstliche Intelligenz KI - wird sie uns
alle töten, wie selbst Elon Musk oder Stephen
Hawking befürchten oder wird sie für den
größten Entwicklungssprung der Menschheit
sorgen?
Was bedeutet die Technologische Singularität?
Auf den Punkt gebracht: Die Künstliche Intelligenz
ist die letzte Erfindung der Menschheit.
Übernimmt sie also die Macht?
Clixoom Science & Future in der spektakulären
Edition Zukunft Rowohlt. - hier gibt es drei
Mal pro Woche spannende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert die Glocke
- nur so verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich Willkommen!
In der Edition Zukunft Rowohlt beschäftigen
wir uns mit den spannendsten und spektakulärsten
Entwicklungen, die laut der Wissenschaft tatsächlich
möglich sind oder uns drohen.
Und zwar mit Themen aus meinem neuen Buch
„Per Aufzug in den Weltraum“ erschienen
im Rowohltverlag.
Und in diesem Buch geht es um unsere Zukunft,
um realistische Szenarien, wie sie aussehen
könnte, wissenschaftlich begründet.
Wer also einen Blick in die Zukunft werfen
möchte, der sollte hier auf den Link zum
Buch unterm i klicken.
So langsam wird die Künstliche Intelligenz
KI allgegenwärtig: Bei Tesla wird sie jede
Woche besser und steuert die Fahrzeuge immer
perfekter, immer natürlicher durch den Verkehr.
Sprachassistenten wie Alexa oder Siri erkennen
unsere Stimme und führen immer mehr Befehle
aus.
Und in der Wissenschaft gewinnt sie aus alten
Daten spektakuläre Erkenntnisse.
KI ist auf dem Vormarsch in unseren Alltag.
Und nicht wenige Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler vermuten, dass sie eintreten
wird: die technologische Singularität.
Es ist der Moment, ab dem Technologie, speziell
Computer, Quantencomputer und Künstliche
Intelligenz (KI), unserer Spezies überlegen
sein wird.
Und das ist nicht irgendetwas harmloses.
Diese Veränderung ist laut dem amerikanischen
Computerexperten Ray Kurzweil „so schnell
und allumfassend ist, dass er einen Bruch
in der Struktur der Geschichte der Menschheit
darstellt.“
Es ist ein Ereignis mit so umfassenden Auswirkungen,
so wird vermutet, dass niemand vorhersagen
kann, was danach geschehen wird.
Es wird alles verändern.
Denn ab diesem Moment wird dann auch die KI
die technologische Weiterentwicklung vorantreiben.
Die Menschheit wird ihr unterlegen sein und
diese Unterlegenheit wird dann von Tag zu
Tag größer.
Die Gegner sagen, dass eine Maschine nie das
leisten kann, was ein Mensch leisten kann.
Das finge schon bei der Kreativität an.
Allerdings sind ja auch hier schon Programme
geschrieben worden, die zum Beispiel kreative
Bilder erstellen können.
Und ehrlich gesagt: Überschätzen wir uns
Menschen da nicht maßlos?
Ist es vielleicht nicht im Gegenteil so, dass
wir intellektuell Maschinen unterlegen sind?
Ist es letztlich nicht nur unser eigener beschränkter
Horizont, der eine solche Entwicklung für
unmöglich hält?
Wie kann es sein, dass eine intelligente Spezies
sich immer wieder selbst die Lebensgrundlagen
entzieht, in dem sie die Ressourcen um sich
herum verbraucht?
Der Klimawandel ist da ja nicht das erste
Ereignis.
Menschliche Kulturen gehen immer wieder unter,
weil sie ihre Lebensgrundlagen zerstören.
Vielleicht sind wir also gar nicht so außergewöhnlich.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist Künstliche
Intelligenz inzwischen in der Lage, immer
wieder außergewöhnliche Dinge zu vollbringen.
Der Sieg von AlphaGo über den besten Go-Spieler
der Welt war da nur der bescheidene Anfang.
Wenig später hat Alpha Fold mit der Faltung
von Enzymen seinen Vorgänger Rosetta um fast
das 10 fache übertroffen.
Immer wieder berichte ich auf Clixoom über
Studien, bei denen ein Algorithmus mit KI
riesige Datenmengen durchforstet und so zu
vollkommen neuen Erkenntnissen gelangt.
KI macht es möglich.
Und hier zeigt sich, dass KI dem Menschen
auf einem Gebiet schon heute überlegen ist:
Big Data: Große Datenmengen.
Das menschliche Gehirn kann damit überhaupt
nicht oder nur intuitiv umgehen.
Es ist uns unmöglich Millionen oder Milliarden
Beobachtungsdaten oder Varianten einer Sache
durchzurechnen.
Wir können uns nur durch Ausschluß langsam
zum Kern vorarbeiten und verlieren auf diesem
Weg zahlreiche Informationen.
Oder es dauerte unfasslich viel Zeit.
KI kann immer wieder zahlreiche Kriterien
auf das große Ganze anwenden, währenddessen
die Gewichtung der Kriterien über die Rückkopplung
der gefundenen Ergebnisse verändern und sich
so innerhalb kürzester Zeit selbst optimieren.
Beim Menschen ist das ein langwieriger Prozess.
KI ist bei dieser Aufgabe deutlich schneller.
Und schon heute ist sie sehr erfolgreich.
Auf YouTube zum Beispiel ist der auf KI basierende
Algorithmus extrem gut darin, ein wirklich
interessiertes Publikum für jedes einzelne
Video zu finden.
Oder eben der Autopilot bei Tesla.
Gerade wurde die erste Betaversion ausgewählten
Leuten zur Verfügung gestellt und schon wird
sie immer besser.
Noch macht sie auch eklatante Fehler.
Aber und das ist eben der alles entscheidende
Punkt: Sie verbessert sich Woche für Woche
signifikant.
Das sind zwar immer nur singuläre Fähigkeiten,
aber genau das ist der nächste Schritt zur
Technologischen Singularität.
Wenn es die erste KI mit verschiedenen Algorithmen
für unterschiedliche Aufgaben gibt und die
sich gegenseitig optimieren, dann könnte
es innerhalb von Monaten oder Wochen eine
dramatische Entwicklung geben.
Und in der Medizin werden immer neue bahnbrechende
Erfolge erzielt.
Daniel-Adriano Silva von der University of
Washington und sein Team haben eine körpereigene
Substanz für die Immuntherapie gegen Krebs
“weiterentwickelt”.
Und das ist wahrhaft revolutionär.
Es geht um das Protein Interleukin-2, dass
eigentlich ganz wunderbar gegen bestimmte
Krebsarten eingesetzt werden könnte.
Eigentlich, denn in größeren Mengen ist
Interleukin-2, obwohl körpereigen, giftig.
Das Forschungsteam hat aber etwas spektakuläres
unternommen: Es hat den Stoff weiterentwickelt
- und das per Computer.
Wirklich unglaublich: Die Wissenschaftler
haben mit der Software “Rosetta” das Protein
Zug um Zug variiert und verbessert und das
Ergebnis dann in der Realität nachgebaut.
So wurde Interleukin-2 immer weiter optimiert
und schließlich so umgebaut, dass es kaum
noch aussah wie das Original.
Es war zudem weniger schädlich und stabiler
als das ursprüngliche Protein.
Bei Mäusen lassen sich damit bereits Darm-
und Hautkrebs erfolgreich behandeln.
Und Rosetta ist eben nur halb so intelligent
wie Alpha Fold von der Google Tochter Deepmind.
Damit wird offenbar: DNA-Sequenzen sind Daten.
Mit denen kann man rechnen.
Ein Computer hat das jetzt mit überragendem
Erfolg getan.
Und während die Kapazität von Rosetta noch
ziemlich schwach ist, gibt es bereits einen
Wettbewerber, der fast die zehnfache Leistung
bringt.
Rosetta ist nämlich eine Software, die beim
CASP13-Wettbewerb eingesetzt worden ist.
Hierbei geht es darum, aus DNA-Sequenzen als
Ausgangspunkt für Proteine zu errechnen,
die aus diesen Sequenzen entstehen.
Wieviel von 40 Proteinen werden korrekt berechnet?
Darum geht es bei dem Wettbewerb.
Wie sehen sie nachher aus?
Wie sind sie gefaltet?
Das ist in der Medizin entscheidend.
Je nachdem, wie sie aussehen, sprich gefaltet
sind, können sie Gutes und Nützliches tun
oder auch schlimme Krankheiten wie Alzheimer,
Parkinson oder BSE hervorrufen.
Bei BSE sind es zum Beispiel Prionen, atypisch
gefaltete Proteine.
Sie lösen mit dem Creutzfeldt-Jakob-Syndrom
eine schwere Krankheit aus, die das Gehirn
zerstört und schließlich zum Tod führt.
Falten ist genau das richtige Bild für den
Aufbau von Proteinen.
Es ist ein bisschen wir Origami, nur dass
es nicht um ein paar dutzend Faltungen geht,
sondern um so viele Faltungen, die man brauchen
würde, um ein Tier vollständig und lebendig
für das richtige Leben zu entwickeln.
Also eine nicht ganz so leichte Aufgabe.
Kein Wunder, dass der Zweitplatzierte nur
drei der 40 verlangten Proteine korrekt gefaltet
hatte.
Das war Rosetta.
((ZÜ:)) Proteine aus dem Rechner
Gewonnen hat das Team der Google-Tochter Deepmind.
Es hatte ja bereits mit AlphaGo gezeigt, dass
es Bahnbrechendes leisten kann, dem besten
Go-Spieler der Welt.
Für den Faltwettbewerb wurde Alphafold entwickelt
(Falten heißt auf englisch fold).
Und Alphafold hat 25 der 40 Proteine korrekt
gefaltet.
Mehr als die Hälfte, fast die zehnfache Menge
des Zweitplatzierten.
Dieses Ergebnis wird die Medizin revolutionieren.
Es zeigt wirklich weitreichende Perspektiven
auf.
Wenn diese Maschine in der Forschung eingesetzt
wird, dann werden solche Fortschritte alltäglich.
Die Menschheit wird einen Riesenschritt in
der Krebstherapie machen und in der Behandlung
von vielen weiteren Krankheiten.
So oder so wird KI die Menschheit entscheidend
nach vorne bringen.
Die Frage ist nur ob sie uns alle vernichten
wird, wie zum Beispiel Elon Musk befürchtet
oder auch Stephen Hawking.
Eine überlegene Spezies hat bisher immer
die unterlegene vernichtet oder zumindest
massiv unterdrückt.
Aber im Gegensatz zum Klimawandel scheint
die Politik hier zu reagieren.
In der EU wird es genaue Richtlinien geben,
die die Entwicklung regeln.
Und Elon Musk plant mit Neuralink ein Computer-Hirn-Interface,
mit dem wir Menschen die KI beherrschen.
Der Prototyp ist schon fertig.
Dieses und viele andere Themen aus unserer
Zukunft findet ihr in meinem neuen Buch „Per
Aufzug in den Weltraum“.
Das gibt es unter anderem im Clixoomshop auf
Amazon..
Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei seid und Clixoom
treu bleibt.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!